seit mehr als 20 jahren kämpft sie um
ihr erbe um wertvolle gemälde von paul
klee oder piet mondrian anita templin
hat sich deshalb schon unzählige male
mit ihrem anwalt in leipzig getroffen
templins großmutter die kunstsammlerin
so viele sitze küppers 1927 folgt sie
angewidert vom aufkommenden faschismus
in deutschland ihre man in die
sowjetunion die sammlung überlässt sie
einem museum in hannover
leihweise doch die nazis werten sie als
entartete kunst und beschlagnahmen sie
raubkunst anita templin will die bilder
ihrer großmutter zurück
es geht um gerechtigkeit in erster linie
und auch im interesse meiner großmutter
die ja ihr leben lang kämpfen musste und
gekämpft hatten die sicher auch jetzt
noch wie ein löwe um ihre bilder kämpfen
würde dass man nie einfach sagt naja gut
füße weg sondern das einfach mein
versuch die gerechtigkeit
wiederherzustellen und das alles dahin
kommt wo es hingehört
einige bilder könnten sich in der
sammlung dieses mannes befinden
cornelius kolig in seinem münchner
appartement hat er jahrzehntelang rund
1400 kunstwerke gehortet keiner wusste
von dem schatz der laut experten
vielleicht einen wert von 30 millionen
euro hat gold über nahm die bilder von
seinem vater dem auftrag hitlers mit
kunstwerken handelte die
staatsanwaltschaft beschlagnahmte die
sammlung verheimlichte den fund aber
mehr als ein jahr lang im ausland ist
man empört über deutschlands umgang mit
mutmaßlicher nazi raubkunst zu recht
findet erben anwalt georg kestel
es ist wirklich über die jahrzehnte mehr
vertuscht verleugnet auch wirklich
offenkundig gelogen worden als zur
aufklärung beigetragen worden und zwar
auf allen ebenen die damit zu tun haben
im kunsthandel in den in den museen und
in den privaten sammlungen auch kastel
vertritt die erben von max liebermann
zahlreiche werke des jüdischen künstlers
galten als verschollen
jetzt sind sie bei görlitz wieder
aufgetaucht das die erben die bilder
zurück bekommen ist aber
unwahrscheinlich
nach 30 jahren dürfen private sammler
und stiftungen diebesgut behalten
das heißt der heutige besitzer kann sich
theoretisch darauf berufen dass der
herausgabeanspruch des eigentümers
verjährt ist für staatliche museen gibt
es zumindest eine moralische
verpflichtung
deutschland hat eine erklärung
unterzeichnet kunstwerke die die nazis
gestohlen haben sollen den eigentümern
wieder zurückgegeben werden
manche erben sehen darin eine chance sie
haben sich an die historikerin monika
touchco gewarnt die weltweit nach 4000
raub kunstwerken auch in den museen
sucht doch in deutschland bleiben ihr
viele türen verschlossen
meine forschungserfahrung im
europäischen ausland sind da ganz
anderer natur interessanter und
erstaunlicherweise zum beispiel in der
schweiz habe ich bislang überhaupt noch
gar keine einschränkungen erlebt im
kunsthaus zürich beispielsweise stellt
man mir im archiv alle unterlagen zur
verfügung die mich interessieren
gleiches gilt für die niederlande auch
dort gibt es keinerlei irgendwie
geartete forschungs einschränkungen
anita templin und ihr anwalt hoffen dass
der goldfund eine wende bringt eine
größere bereitschaft seitens der
sammlungen egal ob privat oder staatlich
geführt sich mit den erben zu einigen
denn viele kämpfen wie anita templin
seit jahrzehnten um ihre familien
kunstwerke viele haben es auch einfach
schon aufgegeben denke ich wird auch
sicher einige geben die die gewesen das
ist dass es noch kunstwerke gibt die
ihre familie mache ja dann
selbst wenn sich einiges in sachen
raubkunst zu bewegen scheint der fall
collette weckt den verdacht dass es
nicht genug ist als fußball zwischen
formellem recht und moralische
legitimation ist hier sehr groß und ich
bin der überzeugung dass das deutsche
parlament sich dieses problems annehmen
muss und eine rechtliche regelung finden
muss wie das korrekt in ordnung gebracht
werden kann
woche für woche werden mehr und mehr
bilder aus dem golf und in einer
datenbank veröffentlicht
nun melden sich mögliche eigentümer noch
freiwillig will kurt sich von seinem
schatz nicht trennen
ich hoffe sehr dass es gelingt der
bundesrepublik dem freistaat bayern wer
immer zuständig ist
mit herrn gründet ein vernünftiges
einvernehmen zu erzielen es darf doch
nicht sein dass ein alter mann auf stur
schaltet und der schaden dadurch immer
größer wird dass man diesen ganzen
probleme nicht angemessen lösen kann
anita templin hat hinweise darauf dass
auch ein gemälde aus ihrem
familienbesitz in der sammlung görlitz
sein könnte
sie will weiter für die rückgabe kämpfen
dass sie ihrer großmutter schuldig